[Musique]
l'humanité approche le cap des 5
millions de décès attribuables à la
coved 19 mai près de deux ans après le
début de cette hécatombe plusieurs
questions quant à l'origine du virus
demeure sans réponse il manque des
pièces à cet immense casse tête une
équipe de l'émission découverte a voulu
remonter à la source cinq mois de
travail au total après la diffusion de
leurs reportages ils ont reçu une
avalanche de courriels dont les contenus
sont parfois déroutant et fait
intéressant au décrypteurs nous avons
aussi reçu notre lot de messages qui
nous laisse assez perplexe
werther bonjour salut bonjour
on accueille avec grand plaisir been and
que sa lubie nan bonjour alexis on
n'avait pas le choix de faire appel à
toi parce que autant du côté de
découverte que des décrypteurs on se
retrouve dans une sorte de tempête
récemment à la faveur du est ce qu'on
peut appeler ça du retour en force d'une
thèse parmi d'autres sur l'origine du
virus est de la fuite de laboratoires de
produits de reportages sur ce sujet
personne ne veut être coupable de
décisions qui ont peut-être entraîné des
millions de morts nous on en a parlé
quant à marquer qu'on a su nil la
première année depuis le début de la
coved innove en mars thermique est ce
qu'on sait sur le régime de la copie 19
mai on a des éléments d'information
beaucoup de désinformation à combattre
aussi mais ya pas grand-chose de coulées
dans le béton
ce qu'on disait puisque dix binômes dans
ce reportage somme toute ça se ressemble
quand même mais maintenant binam de
toute évidence d'un reportage jeunes
eurent brasser la soupe quel genre de
réaction tortue toi mais toutes sortes
de réactions ce qui était surprenant
c'est qu'on a eu beaucoup de réactions
favorable et du genre je le savais je le
savais depuis le début et donc on a reçu
comme si c'était ça permettait de
l'accréditer beaucoup d'autres
hypothèses en même temps la possibilité
que ça a été fait en laboratoire on
savait que c'était fait en laboratoire
depuis le départ que ça a été fait dans
le but d'imposer des mesures en place et
c'est donc on dirait que le simple fait
de dire que c'est possible qu'ils aient
une fuite de laboratoire ça donnait du
crédit à tout le reste donc que ce
laboratoire qui ce virus a été fait
volontairement que ça a été fait dans le
but de contrôler la population de vie
davantage de contrôles au gouvernement
dont vous n'avez comme si c'était le
début d'un immense complot qu'on était
en train de déterrer un malentendu parce
que le fait que ce soit probable
malepère ça veut pas dire que ces sautes
ses produits absolument pas pu mais nous
on a reçu énormément de lettres aussi
puis allez vous vous rétracter vous
excuser allez vous dénoncez vos
collègues conspirationnistes c'est que
c'est complètement fou mais en même
temps nous on n'a jamais exclu cette
théorie là tout ce qu'on disait c'est
qu'à la lumière des informations solides
qu'on avait en mars dernier il rien qui
permettait de croire que c'était ça qui
s'était produit dans beaucoup de médias
on disait que c'était une théorie qui
relevait du complot vous vous l'avez
jamais dit mais ça a été dit à
nombreuses reprises et c'était une
théorie dont on n'osait pas vraiment
parler ou autres qu'on n'allait pas au
bout de cette question là de manière
publique en tout cas ça c'était en mars
2021 si on remonte encore plus en
arrière dès le début binam la thèse
l'hypothèse privilégiée est celle de
l'évolution naturelle de passage de
l'animal à l'humain pourquoi dans bliss
tessa qu'on favoriser davantage comme
qu'on favorise est dans une époque c'est
ça mais qu'on favorisées comme hypothèse
pour plusieurs raisons mais une des
principales raisons est simplement parce
que c'est ce que l'histoire nous a
enseigné parce que par le passé les
pandémies les épidémies passé sont
souvent venus du monde animal et aussi
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de virologiste
qui avait prédit qu'on aurait
éventuellement une prochaine pandémie de
type sera sous de ce genre là qui
proviendraient de la chaufferie donc ça
semblait naturel d'avoir cette hypothèse
là et aussi dès le départ il ya eu des
lettres en fait en particulier de
lettres de un article lettres qui ont
été publiés dans nature medicine et
l'autre dans la revue de l'inde cette
possible des revues prestigieuses de
scientifiques qui ont immédiatement
écarté dans un corps sain dans un
article dans les dom et de cm2
virologiste qui ont étudié la séquence
qui disait que tout scénario d'origine
deux laboratoires étaient à leur avis
non plausibles noms possibles et de
l'autre côté il ya eu une lettre
d'opinion dans le 27 août on avait 27
scientifique qui visait mais alors il
disait spécifiquement toute théorie
autre que celle d'une origine naturelle
et complotistes est de l'ordre de la
théorie du complot est donc
immédiatement ces mots-là cette pensée
la été reprise par de nombreux médias et
c'est normal parce qu'en tant que
journaliste scientifique quand il ya un
article est publié dans de l'inde c'est
tout dans les chemins de sin on lui
accorde du crédit par la suite baissé ce
qu'elle fait si elle donnait
l'impression qu'il ya eu un consensus
scientifique autour de cette question la
plus de 18 mois plus tard on est
toujours au même point on peut pas dire
de façon claire que c'est une ou l'autre
des théories qui doit ou qui peut
prévaloir scientifiquement est-ce que
suffisamment de preuves pour accréditer
une ou l'autre on en n'est pas l'un
c'est ce que démontre toute la recherche
qui a fait le ms c'est ce que démontre
la recherche qui a été commandé par joe
biden à ses services de renseignements
c'est qu'en ce moment on n'arrive pas à
trancher ce qui a beaucoup changé en un
an et demi c'est le crédit qu'on accorde
à cette possibilité là donc il ya un an
et demi on en discutait pas maintenant
l'om s on parle l'om est dit que c'est
une hypothèse qu'il faut investiguer
comme joe biden comme de plus en plus
scientifiques qui ont finalement réussi
à a publié plusieurs lettres
dans diverses revues qui ont permis de
dire ce n'est pas complotistes d'en
discuter et il faut l'envisager parce
que jusqu'à présent un an et demi plus
tard cette question n'a toujours pas été
investiguées est en effet si on regarde
l'ensemble des preuves et l'ensemble des
circonstances il n'y a rien qui permet
de trancher définitivement ni d'un côté
ni l'autre d'éliminer lan ou d'éliminer
l'autre évident on dit souvent en
sciences que bon dxy des affirmations
extraordinaire demande des preuves
extraordinaires on s'entend que l
hypothèse la fuite de la beauce ça reste
pas mal de plus extraordinaire que
une origine animale un autre
intermédiaire le classique qu'on a vu
que je pense 60 % des maladies qui nous
touche c'est pas mal sur le patin
maintenant est-ce que c'est preuves
extraordinaires la honte vraiment
trempées là dedans est ce que tu penses
qu'on va les avoir ce si elles existent
nous va falloir se résigner à peut-être
ne jamais savoir moi j'ai pas de boule
de cristal mais si ces données là existe
alors il ya plein de choses qui peuvent
se passer là est ce que est ce qu'il ya
des collaborateurs de l'institut de
virologie de wang donc si l'institut
dont on parle quito car les accusations
c'était un laboratoire qui travaillent
avec beaucoup de collaborateurs externes
avec avec donc des gens qui détiennent
de l'information des revues des éditeurs
qui détiennent de l'information s'est
rendu compte et c'est pour ça que des
battants évolué au cours des derniers
mois qui est normalement d'information
qui a fuité de ses collaborateurs
externes qui nous permet de faire
évoluer le débat puisse comprendre un
petit peu plus ce qui se passait dans
l'institut de virologie à ce qu'un jour
par un moyen ou un autre on doit pouvoir
mettre la main sur ces données là
tout peut arriver là la science
le processus fait que des fois ça prend
du temps des fois on avance des fonds
recul des fois on bifurque jeudi c'est
normal
parfois dans le processus de se tromper
pillot des scientifiques qui changent
d'avis le précisément avec cet exemple
là il y en a un moment donné que signer
la lettre comme quoi oui faut
investiguer l'origine de laboratoire qui
commence à regretter un peu on a vu
beaucoup du contraire aussi exactement
des deux clans la science par définition
c'est ça parce qu'autrement la recherche
de la vérité mais c'est plus de la
science et de la religion quand d'autres
jamais conformé jamais rien en question
qui confrontent jamais et si on vient
tout dépend de mentionner ces deux
études mais tuées et 27 sur lesquels on
s'est rabattu assez rapidement
journalistique mans c'est ce qu'on a
fait est-ce que c'est pas une première
pour nous jean n'a laissé que des
remises en question qu'on a à faire
c'est sûr que c'est tout le coeur de la
question en ce moment là c'est que on
s'est rendu compte malheureusement très
tard qu'une de ces deux lettres là avait
des conflits d'intérêts majeurs donc il
y avait probablement en tant que
journaliste scientifique on aurait pu se
poser la question je pense plutôt dans
la situation dans lesquels on était
l'année dernière je pense que tout
journaliste se pose est mille fois la
question avant d'aller semer des doutes
dans la population sur sur sur
l'hypothèse de laboratoires parce qu'il
y avait tellement d'hypothèses y avait
tellement de y avait tellement de
n'importe quoi qui circulait sur les
origines possibles du virus que tu dis
ok avant d'aller en discuter puis
allende avant d'en parler on va y penser
50 x qui ne serait ce qu en effet que
par le fait que le président donald
trump en part ça fait qu'on la question
est devenue encore plus difficile à
aborder ça nous a mis dans une situation
c'était très difficile d'aborder
correctement ces sujets là puis ça nous
interroge en effet sur notre relation
entre les la narration les porteurs des
différents les différentes hypothèses
piqué ce que commencer influence notre
travail en tant que journée les sites
répartis de notre responsabilité c'est
sa tentation quelque chose
autant avoir des preuves assez solides
pour ne pas dire béton parce que vous
faire attention là on le voit avec la
réception que certaines personnes ont eu
de ton reportage le c'est hyper facile
de sauter aux conclusions de prendre des
raccourcis de retenir juste ce qui fait
notre affaire si son fourneau bien puis
de tout laisser tomber le reste ça c'est
extrêmement dangereux oui c'est un
réflexe très naturel surtout dans un
contexte où nous avions été bouleversé
où certains ont perdu des proches ou on
est déstabilisé et où on est en quête
réponse je pense qu'un instinct que
plusieurs on sait le trouver des
réponses
lorsqu'elle est plus simple et qui
confirment certains billets pour voir ou
revoir les reportages de been and à ce
sujet rendez vous sur tou.tv barres
obliques découverte sachez aussi qu'un
article inspiré de ses reportages est
disponible sur radio canada.ca